[Music]
and woman's best friend news submitted
by anything as possible a woman married
her dog after giving up on men don't
blame you
following hundreds of failed dates I
wonder if she lived in California she's
a dog there was it was a YouTube video
this go like promoted [ __ ] her dog
that's creepy but I feel like everyone I
have so much to say about everyone in
California basically isn't a [ __ ]
relationship with their animals am I not
right right it's like they're more about
the animals and us but how bad were
those guys that she's [ __ ] this dog
now they were obviously everyone in
California yeah except for you guys sure
you're great but you know we are very
great maybe for notice no no no well
guys this just a guy oh you have a dog
it's not mine it's I'm just an ant you
know but like I love the dog but she can
be a [ __ ] like I have to like excuse
her personality and [ __ ] like when new
people come around like she's like one
of those dogs that's like listen and she
looks better online oh wow I should do
any of your friends yeah give her
friends come over and kind of give her
dog with luck the dog will look at them
with weird looks and be like [ __ ] you
who are you and then leave I see yeah
she'll make her presence known and then
just be like sassy [ __ ] this time she's
a Hollywood dogs
she's like no nobody famous and she
leaves yeah I can't get famous off of
you that's the truest [ __ ] ever how many
followers you have on Instagram are you
verified man go to a Hollywood party
dude everyone just looks through you
until they find a famous person so true
it's so true Oh famous mm-hmm let me
gravitate toward that person uh-huh the
guy I like do you guys have you ever
been like dating before you guys met
before all of you guys were linked up
and everything if we ever like yeah I
was the opposite I actually dated like
12 dogs and then I was like I'm over
dogs so I I scoured gee well the dogs
were terrible yeah they really
understand me that well he got the real
badge
exactly
and yet communicating on dogs is always
difficult I can't [ __ ] a dog they're
like my children that's good that's a
healthy relationship and why do you took
the stand mm-hmm I have to stand for
something so I don't stand for much but
when it comes to [ __ ] dogs I do not I
do not approve so the dogs can [ __ ] oh
my lord I can't believe we've ever had a
problem monetization this woman her name
is Elizabeth she's 49 years old she's a
former swimsuit model in case you guys
are wondering really all right so she
has had about 221 dates she counts
that's like very specific it's very
specific and so she said that she had
four failed engagement oh damn that's a
lot doesn't that say more about her and
her partner's she's a [ __ ] bass bro
that good I'm saying this is what this
looks like
so she's a disaster oh she's married
with that book dude that's a [ __ ]
shoot off your old a dog what if the dog
didn't want to marry her that's [ __ ] dog
named Logan don't you feel like they're
all like control freaks people that are
super like into their animals cuz
they're like I can control you maybe
she's like that maybe I think that
relationship didn't work out because
she's like oh you're not listening to me
well people do want to treat their
partners like pets it's like every time
they do something good like I like you
and mm-hmm like stop
leave it put it down yeah I could
picture at the honeymoon the dog holding
the lady like this so her okay so then
she went on this show called this
morning this British morning talk show
and that's when she decided to marry her
dog live in front of thousands of
viewers and so during her her what's the
word mouth
yeah it's that she ended up saying all
that I have in my doggy treats cupboard
I promise to give to you it's publicity
yeah it was but no she doesn't seem like
she needs attention at all no exactly
she was like really confident within
herself I think she she ends up saying
and all those cuddles on
sofa I share with you with my body I
promise to take you for daily walk youth
was a very meaningful boss yeah it's in
the doggie Larry
Robert wrote a wedding brief and I was
like that I love that it starts looking
as nuts
yeah that's the right size for the dog
I'll show you guys the video clip right
now of their ceremony that's not [ __ ]
cute though he looks like a big sheep
and all those cuddles on the sofa I
share with you and all those kernels on
the sofa I share with you that Logan is
feeling a little bit rough this morning
so chem the only place the ring with
Elizabeth and Elizabeth could you place
the bracelet on to Logan's Paul please
[Music]
do you agree to take Elizabeth to be
your partner for life that's exactly how
my wife and dog because hate that as a
yes I pronounce you now as dog and woman
I mean though she'll never have to go
through his [ __ ] phone you know what
I mean like she'll never have to worry
about that while he's he's smelling all
[ __ ] [ __ ] all day though what
about that at least that's in front of
you you know what you're dealing with
yeah woody starts humping her like now
what is she gonna do divorce some
because oh yeah you should probably
never done him sorry Noah Joe of things
probably never takes them to the dog
park is that you're saying like how she
controlling yeah you did for her
bachelorette party she party with a
bunch of dogs is one last time ah I got
the shelter or something
you still laid on the floor and they all
liquor well she did rescue Logan from
the shelter so maybe she went back to
the same one one more time yeah let it
all out
how do you divorce the dog he better get
us yeah oh just drive down an unfamiliar
street and open the door dude all be
tied to you this doesn't work out either
even she [ __ ] runs away like she
leaves a door open one day and he
[ __ ] runs away it it's like damn all
these people [ __ ] run away even
adults funny that's so funny
I bet she's chick though she's like you
ain't leaving me a mother [ __ ] oh yeah
that's another thing you could do to
you'll always have access to their
location you don't need [ __ ] find my
friends like that you're getting a chip
I want to be chipped why if I get
kidnapped I want someone to come find me
what do you have if you want to take
from you I'm [ __ ] VIP girl you don't
even know what do you have that people
won't have my own country actually I'm
gonna get you - that's a good idea
why what if I get kidnapped and I like
my boy I ask you the same questions but
what do you have that I want to get ya
what you I want to get cuz what if I get
kids you know how does the kidnap you
gesture you like a stretch limo it's
like I want a GPS chip yeah that's what
I'm talkin about
same I want people to locate me friends
and family they know where I'm at you
just put it on your watch
no but then they might take it off I put
in a molar like him just stick it in
your
thinking like you just talked about
sooner what if they used a chip to find
us to kidnap us no but then that's like
our only friends and family though there
doesn't even what if they hack into it
though no it's not on the phone
well what if we go scuba diving right
died and she doesn't know how or where I
died I know you tell me you went scuba
diving so I know that you know by he's
in a deep deep ocean and no one can find
and now you're gonna find me with
satellites I'm always right there
but you're dead so what's the point I
shouldn't get my a she's your dad how
does she consummate her marriage
Oh with the dog I hope she did it cuz
she did doggy style that's why I was
like saying that joke why with whipped
cream or peanut butter or peanut butter
I respect your choices it's peanut
butter dude I would have chosen what
cream but is it abuse if the dog's
[ __ ] her yes first night but it feels
good for the dog though he doesn't want
that [ __ ] doesn't depend at the dock
smiling or not oh do dogs smile cuz I
see dogs smiling but I don't know if
that really means that me love smiles
all the time stretching the lips nervous
but he is the same face when he's hot
though the Saints Riley kind of face
when they're hot no-goods go like this
and it goes okay then he's happy but
then he pees on you doesn't it yeah it
doesn't cut it doesn't curl up that way
oh that's cute
gosh all the people that are into
bestiality are gonna be so into this
video well no they're gonna think that
she's like making light of marriages to
dog I hope yeah they get upset
mmm-hmm guys so she said that she was
joking with her friends about marrying
Logan and then she ended up thinking
more seriously like wait why not yeah
it's just it's a big funny Stein oh
she's a troll yeah I hope so
I don't think she's a what do you call
it bestiality animal whatever and we'll
talk her I mean if there's people out
there that eat toilet paper she could be
dead serious true I marry walls and
[ __ ] train stations we've seen that
yeah I think the real funny part of the
story is she's like man and I've been
through all this like dates and stuff
and I just you know can't find the right
guy and it's uh everyone else's problem
or engagements more engagements a lot
but then like I don't know to go from
I'm trying to get a man to just
completely giving up on
it's not just men going to a dog does a
guy who married his laptop but then it
died on his wedding one what a night
shut up
not serious truth where'd you find that
story ah years ago guys I'm [ __ ]
married video games all the time in
Japan
yeah I understand giving up on on guys
for a little bit and then just trying
out but never a dog you know what did
you do get like does that mean you wear
less begins well here's a link I figured
out how that works so if you ask a girl
out on a date that means you have to pay
so I've like never done that but I've
like gone out with like girls and was
like oh this isn't for me it still
applies even if you ask with friends
like if I were to say hey do you want to
go eat I should be the one paying for
you oh really yeah I mean unless we just
discuss it we're gonna go [ __ ] or
whatever but I always like do like I
always pay for like what I get because
I'm really weird about that yeah but if
someone invites you that's usually
that's true that's courtesy because you
don't have nice friends the first thing
that's crazy like that's how all of us
operate but I guess there's people I
don't know that well know some of my
friends like Oh we'll be out and like
they expect me to pay for everything
like listen [ __ ] I'm not married
anymore I have a credit card I'm not
expecting that cuz like we go out to eat
all the time but I'm always like to go
somewhere my if I invite all y'all and
then and I expect someone else to pay
like if I invite everybody here to go
eat at this dope restaurant right and I
don't even want to pay in someone pays
for me that's weird right mm-hmm
I know guys are like that really they
must be winners because they never pay
for anything
they're actually huge breadwinners but
they don't want to pay because it's like
a power thing it's so [ __ ] up really
yeah they can afford it they don't pay
well maybe because their wife's at home
and they're like dude my wife will see
this [ __ ] oh hell no I will see it the
statement will be like I will kill you
what you said you tried it out with
chicks are you talking about you data
yeah yeah yeah and it's so funny because
my standard for girls when I did that
because I'm straight I'm straight I'm
straight
did you scissor no I didn't know didn't
you didn't really give a shot I think no
[ __ ] fine which is way more fun than
going down on anyone um yeah just saying
yeah hmm thanks but makes me really
uncomfortable when I say this now
because I don't want people to think
that I'm like trying to hit on someone
like cuz girl
I don't you think I'm hitting on you by
admitting that information how conceited
of me would that be well some people get
that and I'm not in thick my when I did
that I was like gosh my standards for
girls are like so much higher than the
dumbass guys I've dated like they have
to be really attractive like it's like
the 1% wait are you saying we're not no
yes you I'm you stop no kisses you're
professional you're beautiful but like
guys you're like that's not me I'm not
like some like you're not her type
if you were to date a dog you can it be
lower standards or highest and I
wouldn't date a [ __ ] husky [ __ ]
Huskies sorry if you love not just all
of them I got bit in the face by a
[ __ ] husky [ __ ] Huskies they don't
like you got bit in the face by an
individual husky Mew blame all Huskies
that's exactly what I'm doing it's
absurd you know what get bit in the face
by a husky and see if you feel sick tell
you that I'm I'm really good friends
with a husky like I know I'll husky I'm
close with a husky and like what's the
Huskies name he doesn't know that his
name is Amy [ __ ] him Miriam I'm not
taking that what a Maron I mean have him
you can have him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]